so the publication human events reported
today on a new state department
memo it was issued to all embassies
around the world it encourages american
quote diplomatic and consular posts
to display shows of support for black
lives matter tomorrow that would be the
one-year
anniversary of the death of george floyd
the memo says that u.s embassies can fly
a blm
flag and the diplomats should reference
black lives matter in their speeches
should american ambassadors come out
against the nuclear family as blm has
for
socialism as blm has for race hatred as
blm does
every day what the state department
doesn't appear to understand or maybe
this is the whole point is that the
existence of blm is a national
humiliation to the united
the rest world is watching of course
where america they pay close attention
to what we do
listen to these chinese officials from
recently explained that blm
is a sign that the united states is a
terrible place
there are many problems within the
united states regarding human rights
and the challenges facing the united
states in human rights
are deep seated they did not just emerge
over the past four years such as black
lives
matter it did not come up only recently
right so if we ever had a state
department
whose message to the world is yes the
united states is terrible
that's exactly the message that they are
sending that's what they believe
should they be representing us to the
world should people who don't like the
country be running the country
they are the state department did not
respond
to our request today for clarification
they didn't comment at all
so instead we called troy murdock he's a
contributing editor at national review
online
we're happy to have him with us troy
thanks a lot for joining us
what what do you think this the message
here is exactly
actually what the message is not the
message is not the areas in which the
state department ought to be focused
right now i mean just in the last few
weeks
uh we've seen about uh a huge increase
of 944 percent
uh month on month in april of uh illegal
alien encounters on the southern border
we've seen rockets being fired from
hamas iranian rockets but our
beloved allies in israel you had the
colonial pipeline shut down by cyber
hackers who are still
alive and well and on the run in russia
and we're still as you saw that as you
mentioned and discuss the top of the
hour trying to figure out how
a virus got out of wuhan china came here
to this country killed almost 600 000 of
us
i think the state department ought to
spend some time on any one of those
priorities
before turning themselves into basically
the public relations arm of black lives
matter
i mean blm is a political organization
among many other things but it's in
effect a political party i mean should
the state department be promoting a
political
party at u.s embassies in foreign
countries i i can't think of a precedent
for that
uh i don't think they should and imagine
if uh 2025 if
donald j trump is re-elected president
if we have uh president
ron desantis imagine if u.s embassies
overseas were flying flags of the
national rifle association or
or the national right to life committee
i don't equate those peaceful groups
with black lives matter
which has an incredible uh recent
violent uh uh
history uh but imagine what uh people on
the left would respond if you had nra
flags flying over the u.s embassy in
paris the us embassy
in london i don't think they'd be very
happy and i think that uh to have that
kind of a political
organization represented by us diplomats
are supposed to be neutral
and focused on advancing america's
national interests in american diplomacy
those things just seem completely out of
place and totally inappropriate
yeah or how about the flag of the kunan
army
that threatens us i mean maybe we should
fly on army flag
whatever that is over the over the u.s
embassy in moscow imagine such a thing
amazing
yeah it tells you a lot joy murdock
great to see you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else